"John Wick Chapter 4" isn't over by the
time the credits start rolling. In fact,
the post-credits scene might just hint
toward the future of the franchise.
Spoilers for John Wick 4.
After four films, five dogs, and a handful of
High Table seats being vacated, the Baba Yaga
finally bit the dust in "John Wick: Chapter 4."
Parking himself on the stone steps all bloodied
and beaten, he calls out his wife's name and,
seemingly, shuffles off this mortal coil. But
while the world may have lost John Wick, the
assassins network and the allies or enemies
inhabiting it are still in business, as are
scores that desperately need to be settled.
One such feud that spills over following
John's Parisian-based payback is between Akira,
and the former friend of Koji's that killed
him, Caine. In fact, their dispute is so
significant it got its own bit of screen
time in a post-credit scene of "John Wick:
Chapter 4," marking a first for the
film series that we didn't expect.
But what does this sliver of a showdown imply for
a franchise's future that, as far as we know now,
is without its firearm-loving frontman?
Here's where the series could go next.
"What did you think was going to happen?
What did you expect? Huh? Did you really
think this day was never going to come?"
Following the bloodbath at The Continental
Osaka, which saw Caine cut down Koji,
Akira swears revenge against her father's
killer and isn't seen again for the rest of
the film. It's not like Caine is keen to do it,
of course, given that he's under orders to take
John down along with anyone else helping him for
fear of his own daughter being killed should he
fail to do so. It is in the post-credit scene
that we finally see Akira go in for the kill,
hoping to get blood for blood, until a swift cut
to black stops us from witnessing the outcome.
It's an unexpected extra to the story not just
because it follows the climax of John Wick's
journey, but because it's teasing a spin-off
that isn't either of the two already confirmed.
Ana De Armas' "Ballerina" and the TV prequel
show, "The Continental," have been well-known
projects in development for some time and we
haven't caught a glimpse of either so far.
With that in mind, hinting at another area for
the burgeoning franchise to expand with this
plotline is a welcome surprise. For starters, it
means more tales to tell in this world of markers,
trackers, and tailored bulletproof suits, but
also, given the characters and story involved,
this could end up being a "John Wick" spin-off
movie the franchise didn't know it needed.
Since the beginning, John Wick, for the most
part, has been a lone wolf, only showing us
one side of a story and teaming up with other
gunslingers for relatively brief scenes, both
in "Parabellum" with Halle Berry and Lance Reddick
and in "Chapter 4" with Donnie Yen. Interestingly,
these were highlights in both films and a
stylistic choice that could be replicated in a
future movie with Donnie Yen and Rina Sawayama
in a more detailed fashion. Not only could
this potential project tell a complicated story
that pits two compelling characters against one
another, but it could also see them working
together as a team when the dust settles.
We know that Caine isn't a bad guy, and the
actions taken against Akira's family were to
protect his own. This could be the murky middle
ground the potential enemies could meet on,
just like Caine and Wick did, leaving
them to unite and go after the High Table,
the powers that make this world as cruel
and cold-hearted as it is. Sure, Marquis
de Gramont may be out of the picture, but when it
comes to that mysterious organization, that's a
table that has plenty more room to clear. Akira,
along with Caine, could be the ones to do it.
Should they be successful, from there they
could branch off into their own solo films
expanding on a world that has so much
more potential and, more importantly,
so many more killer contracts to be
completed. After all, we're still
waiting to see if we ever see Jason Mantzoukas'
unforgettable Tick-Tock Man back on screen.
"Tick tock Mr. Wick. Tick tock."